Alright, when doing the order of operations, I'm going to start within any
parentheses I have. I need to simplify this container. So I'm going to leave the
3 on the outside. Now I have 4 times 2 cubed or 4 times 2 to the 3rd. I know I
have a choice. This 2 could go with multiplication or with exponents, the power.
I know it should go with the power, because powers take priority. So I have 4
times, 2 cubed is really 2 times 2 times 2, or 8 minus 20 times 2. Okay.
Let's keep going with simplifying this parentheses. I have 3 on the outside.
Now, with this 8, I have a choice. It could be paired with multiplication or
subtraction. I know multiplication comes first. So I'm going to have 32 minus 20
times 2. I do this multiplication before I do this subtraction. My parentheses
is getting smaller which is good. Now the next choice I have to make is with the
20. Should it go with the multiplication or with subtraction? I know that
multiplication comes first before addition or subtraction. So I have 3 on the
outside, 32 minus 40. We're almost done, 32 minus 40 I know that's negative 8 so
I have 3 on the outside times negative 8. Alright if you have trouble with this
part here's what you can do. Remember, subtraction is the same thing as adding
the opposite. I could have 32 plus negative 40. Subtracting positive 40 is the
same thing as adding negative 40. When I think about these two numbers, I know
40 is more negative, so I'm going to have 8 more negatives than 32. So I get
negative 8. And 3 times negative 8 is negative 24. If you got negative 24, nice
work.